hey everyone Tom here watching the
Watchmen podcast we are infrequent as
I'm always at odds to say but I love
doing this podcast I love going back
through the works of Alan Moore and Dave
Gibbons and hesitantly looking at the
works of Jeff Jones and affiliates but
you know this is a watchman podcast as
you may have clocked on from the phone
now from the title and the main thing
that we do is something only thing that
we do is to go through Watchmen you know
that the masterpiece that is
issue-by-issue a page-by-page
dissecting panel by panel and often
having perhaps a an odds view on it a
humorous askance glance at Watchmen and
we are of course huge fans and today we
are going through issue 7 I'm not alone
I have you know the Damned to my lorry
there Archimedes to my Merlin death has
a go man let's get it all that's what
was going through my head as I was
listening to this reading this issue
tonight he's [ __ ] great in it six
very sick severy we're yeah like it yeah
yeah so really really looking forward to
discussing this one Tom Bitterblue for
the lads I'm always saying that it's
it's perfect yeah the more you read it
the more you sort of keep your eyes out
for sex on the panel yeah you know look
I hadn't even considered until this
moment the the cover itself the you know
that there's the smudged frame it's very
intimate his needs it suggests a sort of
delicate touch I don't know what you the
hell you gonna do it's very intimate
but it's a finger on a noise it's
tracing something I don't know you know
it's it's time yeah maybe sort of yeah
it's like a it's like the steamed glass
and Titanic isn't it yeah yeah it is
widget I think which everyone's like
ogee sexy when they're like yeah I mean
back in the day before porn was readily
available you know I mean I wanted porn
back in the day Tom a staff to go on a
three-mile walk to the woods and go
through bushes looking for little scraps
of magazines you know I mean
then that people that work for their
porn back in them days yeah yeah like
now where they are just quickly gone me
phone [ __ ] disgraceful Tom and you
know we are expanding our communications
as is porn with art with our Twitter we
know have a Twitter any watching The
Watchmen historians out there listening
back to this this is the first time ever
announced it would just start it at
Watchmen pod that's Watchmen p OD we're
not gonna be like I mean me and DEF have
very successful to our accounts probably
definition MC and batter out resume
should say you know yeah all over over
so busy with them you know but don't you
follow me
now I've just been talking about black
panther for the last 20 hours when they
say it last night in was [ __ ]
brilliant Aki um he was anything from me
at the premiere it was a costumed event
Tom mm-hmm I got dressed up for it oh I
went in blackface [ __ ] how Tom don't
tell them walking up will being
criticized for being massive racists and
sexist on this podcast oh yeah it was
really good movie obviously didn't go in
blackface no I'm very offended by that
if anyone says oh and the joke is that
old-ass yes what kinda what kind of how
feel bad when Michael B Jordan any I
love that guy
yeah it was good like he's the best
Marvel villain but you know it's not
very hard we're now yeah the lads get
given [ __ ] all lines like Cate Blanchett
got given nothing to do she was throwing
swords at everyone but yeah he was
really really good
really enjoyed it it was a bit like The
Lion King and but it was really
enjoyable and you know it made me you
know it had a whole unique take on the
superhero genre and it was good they
like empowered Africa cuz some people I
mean the president has been calling it a
[ __ ] country so it was good to see
that you know people aren't prejudiced
towards it they wanted to look really
good and it did it's the cradle of
civilization Tom I don't know if you
know that
was aware of that yeah yeah that's where
the Lion King happened so you know it's
obviously important historically and
yeah it was really good movie really
enjoyed it I'm becoming more and more of
a Marvel man every day oh [ __ ] this
Watchmen [ __ ] come on you know here's my
problem with a lot of people say Marvel
DC I am firmly DC we are more comic wise
I'm not really a movie going necessarily
like yourself but my argument is you can
just point to a hundred DC stories that
are like no one really talks about
Marvel Comics so I'm missing some of you
what's Marvel's Watchmen nothing really
old man Logan's really gurdial Marvel
Zombies got hyped up to me massively and
I read it today and I was just like
there this is like the Suicide Squad
comments like it's alright it's not
amazing and yeah the Planet Hulk was
really good
I read that recently World War Hulk was
really good but I'm not I haven't dipped
my toe fully in it which I'm not from
what I've read that the stories are good
but they just don't seem to have the
critical acclaim that DC do and I don't
know why that is I think maybe because
they am a more towards kids hmm and I'm
not slugging people off who read Marvel
comics like you're a [ __ ] sad [ __ ]
they're for kids because I read them as
well you know I mean but yeah I think
they're more sort of child-friendly and
and a lot of the ones that I really
liked like old man Logan there's just
people getting their heads cut off and
stuff on the regs um so yeah maybe
that's got something to do with it
whereas I can see adults sort of
gravitating more towards Watchmen and DC
V for Vendetta from hell that sort of
thing Tom you know nice books that
children enjoyed we always urge people
to get in touch of us watching The
Watchmen pod at Jima calm where we get
some great correspondents but not
necessarily to go through any today oh
yeah oh [ __ ] and talk about Tom we've
said about you if spamming links like
there's no tomorrow at the start of this
podcast hear me
well the reason why you're getting paid
to promote this Twitter or something no
not yet
not yet but um you know hopefully an
upcoming thing that we're doing which
again there's so many premieres on this
episode again I'm really hurt to
announce an awesome get for the show
watch when he's free people I mean we
talk about Dave Gibbons and Alan Moore
pretty much the most obviously but John
Higgins was involved as well who was the
colorist for Watchmen he's you know a
legend really of the English comic book
scene as an artist and a Roya and death
we've only got a guy for a guest haven't
we you were gonna record it in a few
weeks by we you mean you yeah much to do
with it but yeah congratulations on
getting them I'm gonna promise I'm gonna
tone back my being a obnoxious [ __ ]
right and persona and I'll just talk
like a normal person and but yeah really
look imported that like one of the
biggest standout things that Watchmen is
the coloring like we've talked about a
couple of times how it's things like the
black freighter in the the fight scenes
they're often colored in certain ways
that make them really leap from the page
so it's gonna be brilliant getting them
on and I really really want hear what he
thinks about things like Watchmen wha mm
which is pretty much stripped away all
his work so will be interesting I'm not
too familiar with coloring itself I
don't know what exactly goes on in it so
yeah it would be really good by every
couple years I'm learning something more
about comics like I just used to think
that there was one person drawing and
writing it and then I found out like
there's a writer and artist and then
courses a colorist and then there's
someone who does the inks as well who
like goes over the pencils with black
pen and it's it's crazy how much work
goes into them yeah yeah penciler as you
say as well and get in touch of us is
what we want to essentially get to with
John Higgins if you've got any questions
for him at all
that you've ever wanted answered no
matter how obscure I've already asked a
few people who listen to the show of
emailed in and got some great questions
coming up so definitely enjoy excited
for that
but yet John Higgins thing is gonna be
going down soon so definitely keep an
ear for that
follow us on Twitter all our watchman
pod I mean that's enough of the admin
out the way for the times enough you
spam and Tommy [ __ ] spammed about
three different things in ten minutes
dear and me people care well I mean you
know a few people care a few people care
but chapter seven as it is issue seven
we are we are deep in the plot I mean
check prior issues for the for the recap
as it were but we open on the lens which
some people may find a little intimate a
little a little sensual something yeah
money and it gets a very sensual later
on that's it you don't I love the word
lessness yes first page really the sense
of discovery I think more in Gibbons are
adept at this really just conveying a
sense of motion and interest with each
panel and needless to say one of the
standout things from this issue the
early ish early part of the issue is the
disembodied suit which year sort of you
know symbolic relic of the past and here
we see death in these you know page one
especially sort of hangs doesn't it and
watches as Laurie goes about her
business yeah and it's nice that it
opens once again on like a yellow badge
mugging thing where it's got the eyes
yeah yeah the lying across the eyes and
it's just a really once again it's a
nice repetition of that famous Watchmen
motif and it's nice that it's wordless
it just creates an atmosphere and like
sort of dos Ionis to the the basement
which some would describe obviously is
the owl cave and it's a shame that you
know Laurie and night owl on in Watchmen
in Doomsday Clock sorry because night
owls sort of a another Batman archetype
that might have balanced with Batman
better than Rorschach and this day and
what I really like about this issue is
throughout this sort of a nostalgic and
wondrous feel to the work like you
almost gone through your old toy chest
and sort of reliving all the happy
memories that you had so yes we a nice
sex toy chest it might be as well Tom
you know we're getting a bit blue here
but lots of memories you can just tell
by your faces I'm not a whale of a time
yeah like a museum isn't it of course of
course and if you look at the
intricacies on the goggles themselves as
well as we pan out sort of the
reflections grow dimmer until there's
just one little flicker of light that's
echoed by the sort of anomaly on Lori's
finger there that she's pulled up our
self it you know expertly drawn and yeah
the fact that she does it you think that
it's a callback to the past getting
brighter and the future getting darker
yeah yeah I think I think I think so I
think there's just a sense of transience
here you know gotta have the symmetry
her going within Archimedes and you know
like Archimedes has been suggested in a
few things that I've read analysis of
this issue as being quite a sexual thing
in of itself not just the fact that a
Jacke lights fire as we'll get into
later but you know then going inside it
like do you see that yeah definitely
it's sort of like you know Dan Leto gets
discovered for having like this almost
pornographic picture which he keeps
locked away and it's sort of in line
with that where he's you know he's got
skeletons in the basement and it's just
sort of that sensual thing that the
superhero throughout Watchmen is a very
romanticized idea so every time you get
like a symbol of that it does have sort
of a romantic connotation that comes
with it and yes just it's a nice
environment really it's one of the most
sensual environments I've ever been in
Tom yet the motion going in and out of
the thing going below the thing you know
seeing it from all these different
reflections all these different angles
and then on the second page you know
Laurie goes for the - lighter which you
know is kind of a cute archaic it sort
of anachronism in of itself these days
presses the wrong thing I guess as a
juxtaposition there's the world need a
bell between the fire and the brother -
Dragon's title
yeah suppose so I'm I never really
looked at deeply in these pages with
chicka just
gone through them again there's quite a
lot going on no doubt it would have been
another one more as 700 word essays
where where he describes everything but
it's just a nice environment opinion you
know the the superhero lairs always a
very sort of secret thing that not many
people know about and not many people
get to visit either because it's so
hidden away and it's great that they get
to kind of go down there and then it
just opposes it um with Dan being
upstairs and he's he's trying to get
he's filling up the sugar tin again cuz
Rorschach stole stole every favor yeah
we have a flashback which is quite a
concession on malls part storytelling
wise like it's not reality like I
remember the wire the first episode has
a flashback at the end but none of the
rest do and it's kind of like I I I
think it's a it's interesting i but it
helps to page it helps it move forward
it helps him you know get down below and
actually did you do see a fire
extinguisher as Laurie's climbing onto
the ship on the first page actually yeah
but it's not the one that Dan grabs
interestingly but I guess that's some
sort of omen perhaps in Moore's mind but
yeah we have the place suddenly
illuminated this dank room by this
Inferno you know created by this shift
and getting onto the following page then
when he's sort of putting out the
foreign you know we're learning more
about sort of what the ship can do and
you know you sort of realized quite how
powerful my tower was maybe up to this
point
he'd seen almost white silly yeah
definitely it's very good in situations
like this and it's just nice that he
knows exactly what he's doing he's very
controlled and he's just very so
disciplined in his movements he knows
exactly how to handle situations even if
they sort of you know could potentially
be fatal and it just kind of builds
towards the man that he is I mean the
colors on these pages are brilliant like
every time that fire appears in Watchmen
it sort of washes out the entire page
and this is a perfect example of stuff
that you know will be great to discuss
with
John Higgins about mm-hmm and can I just
say we've got John Higgins on the bloody
show make sure your email in and follow
on Twitter and subscribe and share and
like iTunes review and don't you know
definitions patreon and boys gonna be
down because just so if you like sitting
at one time they just rails the cipher
definite now but but yeah you know I
love this a sense of history a sense of
character building that you get from the
two of them like I just like the
structure the issue that it's just about
these two people you know slowly
beginning a relationship yeah it's sort
of like a rebounded he he's a bit of a
rebound Ronnie what dan dreiberg and but
yeah it's nice that they've sort of
discovered this common ground and
they're realizing they've got a lot that
the love about one another mmm-hmm and
the the goggle looking at them at the
bottom of page four as well is yes like
a steamy a guy in a suit isn't it like
voyeuristic mmm like some guy sitting in
the night owl cos you've got you know
just walking in the corn I like like
them days in that Manchester basement
Tom but they're members of dual makers
go back to the Twilight lady said yeah
love which it's kind of a reverse idea
isn't it you know captain carnage was
more of a sort of a perverse superhit
supervillain bats who had those
tendencies but here is someone actively
seeking affection you know in a bit more
of an endearing way and it's just again
a nice inversion on the stereotype for
more yeah and it's everything in this
basement sort of hidden away and it's
the thing that you're embarrassed about
like they Dan talks about at one point
how on reflection it was all very
childish and there's a bit of a
reflection in the goggle Tom I don't
know if you noticed that yeah you would
if you would have completely destroyed
Jeff Jones for dropping that in Tom so
don't don't get mad when you don't get
mad when were does it to you but anyway
there's an entire thing of like late
there's a layer of pornography and
embarrassment
- a lot of Moore's work and it sort of
signifies that men store these keepsakes
I'm sure back in the day before you know
the Internet the men sort of kept these
keepsakes and it was normal to have
pictures of women and stuff but it
really does paint him out as some sad
old man that's desperate to hold on to
the Past even though publicly he says
how embarrassing all is I think it's
mirrored in the fact that he won't let
go of Laurie's hand sort of holding on
to all of this memorabilia and her as
tight as he can right and there's a
level of shame to his love and so this
issue is about losing that shame and
embracing yourself as how you truly are
and and similar to how the costumes
standing at the back of the basement
there's always something in the darkness
waiting that you should embrace and then
you know when he loses his dan dreiberg
mask he becomes night owl and he changes
identities which show that he was never
too attached to the Dan persona he was
always night owl and he couldn't really
let go of it yeah it's nice actually him
not letting go I didn't even consider
that but I really like that Anna I like
when they hold hands as well and there's
suddenly no speech because it is a
worthy issue you know it's very busy
with dialog for the most part between
these two people and then in brilliantly
done I love the costumes that we see in
the back yeah quarantine costume and the
the underwater work one yet so I'm like
a commentary on like action figures and
stuff isn't it because I remember like
buying Batman Forever toys and there was
literally like 700 different things I
weren't in the movie but it was like
spacesuit Batman and underwater Batman
and skiing Batman mm-hmm and there's all
these kind of it's a nice that you get
to see these things sort of that they
existed and he was so prepared for like
every eventual outcome yeah it is it is
very very funny funny little moment
there and they just created in a very a
like way I don't know what
word for our like is like you have
canine for dog maybe there isn't one but
you know I really like the way and when
we later see that one that like almost
broke his on my exoskeleton yeah I love
that because they have a one in a Batman
comic that Grant Morrison did and where
Batman they talk about how the
exoskeleton broke is the the users bones
and so Batman has to inject himself with
man-bat serum and sort of become half
man half bat in order to operate and
it's a nice little call back to that
made me remember the good old days Tom
Archie is you know again being watched
by the guys there and I like how the
smear on the front that Laurie caused
earlier the top of page 7 is sort of
revealing a fleshiness to Dan behind the
the visor yeah there's just so many nice
little things in this issue that you
could easily just overlook yeah yeah
like Laurie talks about how she quit
smoking and but she still gets cravings
for it and it's obviously akin to what
this entire issues about that kind of
lust for for danger and how you you get
cravings to do things even if you know
they are stupid and Dan gives a good
case really for why you would want to be
a superhero in the idea of sort of the
roundtable and being part of a
fellowship of legendary beings and that
that kinship and we get just lots of
that's a very sophisticated in a
brilliant dialogue that doesn't it's not
expository but it is giving you quite a
lot when he's talking about Rorschach
and how they started off together and
because the seeds have been planted by
you know sort of callbacks to it earlier
you know they were partners you know you
get the idea of the day were together
before and they just not nice little
phrases that aren't even that clever in
themselves but just sort of the
characters talking about Osia of how
Rorschach still had all the buttons on
his overcoat yeah I love that bit where
they're kind of implying that he just
went crazy it's like the lights on
upstairs but no one's home and it's
great how they have this romantic appeal
of being a crime fighter which sort of
you know to me deconstructs how it was
very much back
then in comic books as well and if you
read work from the Silver Age there's a
certain purity and innocence to it
that's almost missing now to your
publishers wanted to go darker and
grittier but everyone tends to look back
on the older books I sort of camp you
know very fondly and just in general
this issued it perfectly encapsulates
that ideology of things were better back
in the day when it was a much more
innocent time and that to me is comics
in general and you get an insight into
who know how it is as well as a crime
fighter the smoke bombs the fingerprint
kit the pocket laser you know things
that sort of sort of disabled lights as
well this sort of radio dimmer there's
quite interesting that he then
demonstrates the goggles through as well
and it does again it's it's classic more
that we've discussed to the m4 degree on
here but you know him talking about the
goggles but wink-wink talking about
himself no matter no matter how black it
got when I looked through these goggles
everything was clear as day yeah and
it's nice and it's a nice light romantic
moment you can see the relationship
building between the two even though
they're not really doing that much
they're just sort of learning about
things and it's it's really nice it's
not ham-fisted or anything and you can
sort of see from both sides how one
would appreciate the other and realize
you know that they have much more common
ground than they thought like lorry
slowly realizing that John was very
detached from reality um and she talks
about how she was you know she's a
solitary person and it was nice being
solitary but when she was working with
the government she was always being
watched and under scrutiny and I think
that kind of made her you know it may it
changed him made her realize maybe she
doesn't want that lifestyle mm I am
quite a solitary person um I work from
home by myself I don't go out that much
I used to back in the day Tom but you
know you got you got graphic novels to
read come on exactly and stuff I stuff
to review yeah and stuff I this is
socializing for me in a way you know I'm
just sitting down chatting about comic
books and stuff and and you know I think
if I wasn't a constant observation like
Laurie was even though I do like it I'd
still be like oh this is a bit [ __ ] I
want to go away I just want to be by
myself you know when Dan says he feels
like someone's watching his every move
he flashes to the goggle and this is
constant this persona hanging over him
constantly screaming for him to come
back it's it's nice that the the Nite
Owl costume is very omnipresent and
foreboding and it is always watching him
and he too is under surveillance almost
all the time even if it's just
psychologically in his head it's nice
that they're finding this common ground
and they kind of want to break out of
confinement and be free and and Laurie
doesn't double tees really of where the
relationship is going she's cleaning the
goggles in you know putting the dust off
these costumes and also asks you know if
he has army issue contraceptives so yeah
you know it's there it's it's not Fifty
Shades but it has this point there and
yeah it's a shame that isn't it cuz
that's a good book as well yeah there
needs to be a graphic novel of that I
think yeah pretty great that ask John
Higgins about that maybe I just want to
get loads of questions wrong on purpose
ask him loads I've been calling them
Andrew Higgins for the past three months
in my notes don't know why just an idiot
basically yeah we get a sensible cut
that bear out the show these people are
in terms of their musical interests as
well
Laurie mentions Devo and the sort of
alternative band from the 70s you know
very very costumed very aggressive and
then Dan's mentioned more Billie Holiday
louis jourdan those sort of elements and
again the costume is is looking through
them and I love how when it's dark
archimedes makes a very clear pupil in
the eye yeah and this is constant
flashing back to that I very similar to
the badge
that you know there's a high content
it's the watchman isn't it Tom there's
always something watching and they sort
of travel up and we have a nice sequence
here between those well I always like
the line black as the devil and sweet as
a stolen kiss described in the coffee
distribution okay no really what was
that I suppose it has the word black in
which you love to say Tom don't because
you were [ __ ] racist
first since you called raw black move
left
let's not live long we're gonna help Tom
you're lucky we don't have any listeners
because he'd be in this [ __ ] for that
being Forbes that Dan mentions that he
writes for Warner for Norfolk illogic
ornithological it's kind of difficult to
say journals bird journals and we get
tasted at the end which is pretty
redundant really probably the worst show
you have quite hard to read doesn't have
any second meaning really that I can
defer to please get in touch for us on
the email if you think there is one
we're gonna get an email about that
oh yeah last time I said that yeah yeah
and Bernina if I was the same guy what
was it same guy just this you know but
you would get the TV relating to the
characters what's happened to Rorschach
that he's been captured we get to see in
his apartment as well the whole sequence
is nice right yeah and it's got a slight
allusion to Max Shea being captured as
well I'm not being captured goin missing
so yeah it's it's disgusting the black
freighter as well and it's just slowly
embedding these little seeds into the
world
it also has Laurie saying she got a
letter from the government saying that
she doesn't have cancer which sort of
shows that the press on dr. Manhattan's
ally as well yeah and it's just nice to
when they're watching the news they can
just see how fear-inducing it is this
doomsday counts down and I remember
watching Bowling for Columbine which
discusses in depth how the news is the
biggest fear driving force ever we see
all the time and war terrorism Ebola
SARS bird flu the Millennium book-like
sensationalizes Asian cells and nowadays
everyone sort of offended by everything
and it sort of discusses how apathetic
everyone is and I think that's a problem
in general with society we also lie back
and complain but do nothing about it and
it's nice that as human dies I sort of
came up with this plan because the
people never would have done it they
would have prevented rove themselves to
nuclear war so it's plantain all these
little seeds and and it's still relevant
today like I seen people the other week
discussing that James Bond's really bad
and how sexist he is and how he's your
right breast and stuff and I say well
yeah but he's a fictional character and
the president of America has done most
of the things in real life that bonds
getting criticized for and it's sort of
this subversion of making you focus on
my new things that don't really mean
anything like James Bond um in order to
like take your attention away from
what's really going on and it's nice
that this TV show sort of encapsulates
it's just background noise really isn't
it Tom and and you know people have
always got to have that thing in the
background where it's distracting them
from what's really going on and then we
cut to the Ozymandias performance and
and he sort of laughing on the TV and
it's just a nice little segue that he's
got everyone brainwashed and he's just
laughing at them and amid this we have
the first kiss of the couple which is
done nicely I think as well the steamed
up glass is leaving to the recognition
or the ignition of initial attraction
that been sown throughout the issue and
they have quite a funny little exchange
there you know she's talking what if we
do something with this stupid hair and
you know on the TV in the background
we're getting glimpses of what's
happening but obviously they're very
entranced with themselves and it's very
it's not exactly on the nose I think you
just delivered very well but it's very
clear what is being employed with this
whole sexual metaphor costume idea right
yeah definitely
them sort of undressing net personas and
you know showing who they really are to
one another for for the first time and
it's really romantic you know you know
you've got to get let's get it on on
when you when you read stuff do you
listen to music not normally no do you
know so yeah I do I've gotten Amazon
echo the other week it's one of the best
things I've ever bought Tom and I just
like to listen and like movie
soundtracks or read things and you know
I thought I'll put Marvin Gaye let's get
it on and read this and it heart just
tolling made the work phenomenal the
most sexual stuff ironically in this
initial segment comes from the
Ozymandias innuendos you know him
grabbing bars beginning maneuvers you
know the the grace of his movement his
switch of his grip you know more loves
doing this kind of stuff and I think
this whole section whilst it is we've
read a lot of Watchmen this podcast
there's a lot of juxtaposition I'm not
saying it's not brilliant but there's a
lot of it employed of a technique I
think yet again it's just a marvelous
display of how good they can tell this
story how they established two different
things that echo each other in separate
directions yeah and it's nice that
you've constantly got the lenses
watching on as well
you've got Dan's glasses lens and you've
got the TV lens and they're just being
watched and sort of it's there's a very
boyar istic feel to this and i don't
get--why don't know why but that when
they're like undressing each other
there's that twilight lady pops up again
I do think that's symbolizing his
fantasies yeah breaking out and being
replaced with a real woman or something
yeah it's a nice initially why men were
first readers I thought this was just
laureen's absorb other costume and him
quite yeah it was it was her and he's
kind of reflecting his lens but yet this
whole sequence on page 16 which is I
think the only occasion correctly from
wrong which is what is this and it's
pretty much a 17 panel page yeah you
know it's
Division of what we've got on on screen
here and I love it absolutely love it I
love them tearing each other apart
and it's not a gruesome bloody thing
it's very much been demonstrated as
paper-thin masks isn't it that's sort of
what they show every day yeah
and I'm sure in the movie it was very
bloody when they did this I don't
remember I think now I ripped each
other's skin off and it was like it was
clearly like flesh everywhere and stuff
and blood ba-caw remember I might be
wrong I'm probably wrong again this is
like when you read what German maybe I
just forgot it or you know the certain
things you seen you're like oh yeah I
didn't even notice that before like on
the second row on this page you can see
him sort of gripping what the Twilight
lady's head and then pulling her hair
off as Lori's revealed look I don't know
why maybe I just skipped over that but
it just yeah well this is to say they're
embracing in this apocalypse as well him
jerking open and then probably falling
in love or even more as he wakes up with
her sleeping by him and you know holds a
hand closely and the the repetition of
the atomic explosion in between them
kissing as well mm-hmm yeah alien hand
yeah yeah and it sort of wakes up to
this nightmare he realizes that always
caught her by his side and he holds her
hand and he sort of almost doesn't want
to let go and but he gets up he lets go
and he goes to the window and looks
outside and there's the Sun glaring and
he strikes his finger across the Sun and
it once again creates that watchman
motif of the smiling face and it's just
worse just put so much to work it in so
as Dave Kevin Gibbons obviously and John
Higgins and everything just comes
together perfectly and just works on so
many levels and it's it's did so I'm
almost speechless Tom it's like you know
the classic journey isn't it the sort of
Joseph Campbell that the hero has to go
into the dark cave and
come out a man and sort of confront his
fears and Dan going into his
subconscious here down below and donning
the goggles of beginning his climb into
the person he always really wants to be
and it's nice that Laurie says his only
core of after free and he says I know
because obviously he has the time in his
right eye oh yeah don't even think of
that yeah nice spot yeah so it's just
very again yeah but it's just that's
from multiple multiple readings it's
just incredibly incredibly dense I just
I think I met you before I just started
reading Warren Ellis is the authority
any any listeners get in touch with me
what you think about I've read a few
issues I do quite like it but it's like
it's not it's just not got this level
for me really that I could just you know
keep returning to it but what does and
with Dan I don't know if you felt this I
think he's he's kind of on purpose he's
physically quite inconsistent sometimes
he looks quite fat and overweight so
long as he can look quite you know
muscling yeah I think it's just
depending on what the you know are it's
just going for in portraying him and
he's clearly you know he's clearly
worked out you can see still got muscles
and stuff but he let himself go and and
that's what happens to the best of were
Tom you know an offseason go a bit fat
but you know we've still got it
underneath and the guy can get it back
have you ever seen Rocky Tom I have oh
yeah big there you go there you go you
are is rocky gonna be covered in your
greatest movie podcaster someone picked
that I don't think that I'm actually Tom
we've only done one episode I don't
think it's ever gonna get a second by
the [ __ ] looks of people dropping out
Tom no one's as reliable as you right
people actually have lives you know how
you do about ten podcasts a week no
one's that sad Tom I can't find anyone
else news is pathetic because you are so
it's a bit of a shame well I'll be on
all of your episodes yeah well I checked
out he did The Shining Roy we've
mentioned that before but definitely
came out and Dan finds his true calling
he dons the suit he looks kind of I
don't want to say grotesque I mean it's
quite a weird look with the goggles on
and it's definitely it's not the most
swooping sort of superhero you know it's
not as kind of as darling but he he
looks good you know and yeah I think
Laurie knows what's going on pretty much
instantly and and she obliges yeah it's
a great little thing like suiting up
they often do it movies to have the suit
of montage and it's just a little cool
little thing and you know he's back in
the habit
it's like Sister Act to back in the
habit right right right
and it's just ready for it I don't think
it's anything like Sister Act to be
honest just when I said back in the
Hobby that was the first thing that's in
my mind the sperm and the egg you know
we get night owl we get archimedes going
through these tight tunnels roaring out
above the sea I love these drawings by
Dave Gibbons here above our communities
flying and below it as well as the
tenement building they're brilliantly
drawn yeah and you've got the silhouette
of the the two lovers again graffiti
done the building and it's just amazing
amazing work and yeah it sort of
symbolizes the the phoenix rising from
the fire reborn
much in the same way that Dan and Laurie
are now reborn and you know we see the
Giotto the astrodome sari as well and
then the the fire below and they just
sort of orientate you know orientates
you as a spectator they're looking below
you can sort of work it out for yourself
and survey the scene as they are doing
theatre screens and it's good to see
some you know some old fashioned
superhero [ __ ] rescuing people from
above hoping they don't need to be
fighting and kicking the [ __ ] out of
people they just need to be rescuing
people and I know is that in a lot of
the Marvel movies they do that as well
they just have scenes where the heroes
you know they're not fighting any
villains or anything they're just saving
people there's an absolutely brilliant
one in Iron Man 3 and when he goes on
Air Force One which is crashing and all
the staff and that get rejected out of
it
and he's got a light uses brains in a
suit to kind of catch them all and stop
him from hitting the ground and there's
bitten
the Avengers age of Ultron where they
just go for ages just trying to save
people and it's nice that you know these
people are heroes that they like the
firemen they're like the police force
they're out to save people not just stop
crimes and it's a great little scenario
and you've got the kid talking about how
Jesus and he asks if it's Jesus on his
space rocket and it's sort of to me that
you know anytime Jesus gets mentioned I
do sort of think of the resurrection and
this once again is them getting
resurrected though the characters their
personas are coming back and it's just a
really well thought out little knot in
the books full of it and it's great yeah
it is and it's the realities of this
sort of thing it's the struggle of
getting them out you know it's housing
them it's dropping them off somewhere
safe on something yeah it's very
realistic yeah yeah it is it is I love
it and I love we get to see Archimedes
in loads of different roles as well like
yes all the water cannons spraying out
of the base
it seems dan has room for everything
really here even to give some coffee and
he just that picture of him with the
steering wheel in his hand like like a
pirate like someone on the black
freighter before yeah he's so happy
isn't he yeah he's back the lad is back
and it's gonna be the best time ever and
what better way to celebrate than some
some Nucky and this is what we get here
again with these paneled pages which may
be inclusive to this issue may not be my
memory doesn't serve me well turd
suggests otherwise though love this
sequence this is the classic Watchmen
right yeah this is great
and did you get flashes of the movie as
you were reading this everyone [ __ ]
hates that scene online Tom you know do
they hate their use of that song in that
they say it's a one of the worst covers
ever
[ __ ] no we need to cover the movie
someday soon we need to come think oh
well yeah it'd be easier than covering
[ __ ] 12 issues of this and 12 issues
a Doomsday Clock it'd be done quick yeah
but but yeah I mean there's no longer
impotent as you know no and then
displaying along as well the panels and
you know as you said before the
ejaculating fire and then we also see
the sort of tapering fire underneath as
well just quelled and overall it's a
splendid picture I love the fact that
both of them you know kissing goes
across multiple windows yeah
it's just great and you know sort of
that they are a better fit for each
other than Laurie and ER and dr.
Manhattan were you know they're like
crime fighters the like the dynamic duo
Tom Batman and Catwoman right here and
it's just great and they you know
addressed on the floor in a snake less
you know it's not it's not very lost
goal Z you know it's got a certain
erotic element to it there is a smoking
cigarette held in hand etc etc and it
seems like to me at least Laurie
believes that Dan is kind of not
speaking in metaphors he literally just
wants more sex here but no he wants to
spring Rorschach yeah and he also talks
about how the the world is just all the
wars are just problems to solve as well
which is sort of similar to awesome and
Isis thinking and I sort of think that
shows how these two can relate in the
end Rorschach spoiler alert gets killed
by dr. Manhattan because he doesn't
agree with those indices thinking and I
always wondered why Dan and Laura got
spared and because they're just two
loose ends but this kind of shows no
yeah he you can sort of see why why our
diamond eyes might have done it and it
ends with a face on a yellow moon and
similar to to Archie from the first
panel it's once again and it's just a
nice little poetic
issue what do you make of the quote that
closes it so as he titles brother to
dragons
it's from from job chapter 30 verses 29
to 30 I am a brother to Dragons and a
companion to owls my skin is black upon
me and my bones are burned with heat got
no idea tell it sounds like Geoff Johns
googled it doesn't it I don't get that
one again won't get more in the Bible
maybe yeah maybe it's just for that
reason but yeah we get blood from the
shoulder of Pylos as well which is dry
bugs article very cool again four more
to go into this direction very original
to have it done as an academic journal
piece by one of the characters and
really showing off isn't he very much so
it's so well written yeah I don't know
why that's really to the story but it
just showcases Moe's ability to do
anything really yeah it sort of says in
over like looking at an owl it's a
perfect creature and but in over
analyzing something you sort of lose its
beauty when you look at it sort of
sounds like it's slugging this podcast
off a bit you know what I mean time
right right but yeah it's it's not
amazing it's probably the weakest it's
the first time I've read it to be honest
so I might need to read it again but
it's nothing that stands out massively
that ties into the plot I think
everything else sort of had pop essences
of the plot with sprinkled within it and
so this one just kind of feels like it
doesn't and it sort of feels like a
waste of time but it might not be I
don't know I do really like I'm not that
smart Tom I definitely neither me
neither I do really like though the owl
in the top left and the the rodent in
the bomb right and it kind of like you
know as if it's pied its prey yeah yeah
that's nice yeah yeah okay where did I
just realize that I literally realized
that doing this show by yeah see that as
well because I don't know why I never
I just never put to a good spot that
that's why people listen and issue
for insights like that yeah well they
don't want to hear anything about what
happened in Manchester Tom but we'll
fill up half an hour of the podcast
talking about it anyway and then do ten
minutes of links and spam and then do
ten minutes about the book and that's
the format Tom and I'm sticking to it
that's how it works we will be back my
podcast anyway if you don't like it go
listen to that other watchman podcast
I've heard it's better go listen to that
that's my spam for the episode Tom go
listen to that other thing and give them
a five-star review a little bit shorter
than normal but I just think because of
the issue itself really no we're talking
about sex in it yeah yeah especially
when it's like two sad pathetic podcast
hosts like us you know I mean it's not
exactly we're not exactly well-versed
we're not a porn stars over Tom no let's
be honest Tom especially not you [ __ ]
hell you haven't got any Manchester
stories do you not none they involved
the stuff you were talking about most of
mine are about you know rhymes about
shame I guess we'll be back sooner than
normal because Doomsday Clock is now
bimonthly yes [ __ ] won't be out until
like late March now it's like I I sang
to you before why isn't it like Netflix
why isn't it like it's your contract to
write and draw these twelve issues like
why they give you such lenience because
Jeff Jon this is a busy guy Tom when
he's not listening it was slugging him
off and he's probably he's running DC
isn't he runs all of DC so he's probably
quite busy and it's probably too busy
all right Doomsday Clock properly that's
why it's so [ __ ] [ __ ] and but yeah it
happens all the time like anything by
Frank Miller you've got no chance of
that coming out one time Tom ever sort
of build the hopes up I remember I used
to before digital comics when Frank
Miller was releasing stuff
we'll never used to know that stuff was
getting delayed I used to pay get the
bus in go with the
comic-book shop and they're like oh yeah
saws it's delayed I was like you taking
the [ __ ] piss on ya he's like what
are you have you got some podcast to
record I went what the hell is a podcast
you and it's one of them [ __ ] things on
the internet that only [ __ ] do know
in alright that sounds pretty good I'll
do one of them death how do people get
at you manual your website you chat you
have a video go massively viral recently
right yeah we've had to which is weird
but there were all very clickbait you
Tom a little secret I don't like and I
don't like either of those movies so the
[ __ ] [ __ ] on but the scent is viral I
think I made about 19 pound off them so
thanks very much Netflix mm-hmm
and Netflix don't copyright strike your
stuff either by the looks of it so oh
I'll be in the money soon recording for
the crown then the crown and an
explanation come on 10 things you didn't
know about Breaking Bad yeah with a
little red circle and net thumbnail Tom
always click on it if it's got a red
circle some good creaks out there but
there's just so we're not one of them
yoga your gen you genuinely think we're
good critics on you let us know for good
critics in the comments below don't cuz
I know what you're gonna say you
couldn't say you're not good critics
follow us at Watchmen pod please get in
touch with the show through there as
well we've got John Higgins coming on
we're gonna be very much more
professional when John Higgins comes on
and if you've got some questions well I
think just you should do that episode
you know Tom do you consist a high
chance that I'm gonna [ __ ] ruin it
oh my god we'll see we'll see why I
wanna have you want it though man you're
the show we're the show like it'd be
weird it'd be weird if you weren't on it
looking better I tell you that just be
me like Oh Tom I was putting on some
brown in yellow box as the other day
they were originally yellow you know I
mean but a bit of brown got in there
they reminded me of the badge from
Watchmen what you think about that and
you just be like right lads I've got to
go I didn't realize I think I hear my
mom calling for tea you know I mean
maybe straight off Tom I think it would
actually be better if I stepped away and
you and Johnny interested it yeah that
would be amazing
cuz I think you'd actually like I think
he's probably had the same seven
questions asked to him for the past
three years
yeah whereas I'd probably ask him
something that he hasn't heard before
they are what what did you have for tea
yeah I mean that's the point you know
what have these different sides
colliding there and please people get
the questions to us as well because the
more questions we have yeah the less we
have to do so they'll be they'll be
greatly appreciated save the show please
save the show and send in questions
because yeah the better the questions
the less I'm gonna make it tear myself I
can't listen to these episodes back you
know Tom a genuinely corner get about
five minutes and I think [ __ ] hell
any just and he is I can't accept the
person I am and then there's like a
there's like a body suit there's a
mannequin with some goggles on in the
corner of my room and I just look over
at that and it's just sitting there
breathing heavily now my god the house
back well um you know just to close up
what any any good things you've been
reading lately graphing otherwise no
read Marvel Zombies the Red Planet Hulk
read Suicide Squad like the new 52 stuff
okay the first couple of volumes are
brilliant but then it gets absolutely
[ __ ] oh well like the most mundane comic
I've ever read where it's just like
every everything in the issues pointless
and it all goes back to the status quo
at the end of every issue and it's just
that in Suicide Squad just you can't won
once you realize with Suicide Squad that
they can't actually kill off their
characters it just becomes [ __ ] because
the whole like motif of Suicide Squad is
like who anyone could die any second and
everyone's on the edge but then you
realize like six volumes in they're not
killing these characters off the to
Beeler it's a walk-in dead tom and it
just gets [ __ ] yeah you know I've not
seen it but I've heard it's abysmal now
walking dead yeah it's terrible that was
another video I made that did very well
right I needed Ben this podcast off Tom
and just make these two minute videos
I'm honored I'm honored to be rubbing
shoulders with Cloverfield paradox
explanations as you like them okay this
time but do watch the video okay well
and this has been a fun episode man I
think the issue itself is maybe not the
most notable in the catalog but
regardless we are going through we are
yeah so I probably do watching an
episode before we do Doomsday Clock
right well we're gonna have to at this
rate Tom because it's never [ __ ]
coming out is it I told him outgoing
bimonthly yeah air by weekly the corneum
get it out bimonthly Tom mmm-hmm we
should just [ __ ] release a hardcover
it'll go to the top of the [ __ ] New
York Times booksellers less like you
know yeah well it costs five it's five
bumper issue in it we've got to make
them money that's from doing that [ __ ]
first well um death as always it's been
great man I want to say thank you to
everyone for listening
I think Doomsday Clock will go over the
top 10 top bestsellers list I don't mean
think watch on - let's have a after
market any ill sell well I think they'll
just do I think people have such a bad
reputation of the single issues that
they have you know as people have
started coming round on it as well
that's bad
oh really yeah I've genuinely started
seeing people just be like yeah it's
fine it's alright we're chipping away at
them Tom DC stocks lowering this should
Warner Brothers never should have put
that foot and copyright strike on my
Batman countdown list Tom cuz I'm [ __ ]
chipping away at their stocks now like
we all got I get it I'm quite scathing
like I do know that Bob it's from a
place of honesty it's from a fan of
Watchmen and Tom strong and any other
Alan Moore stuff that I suck off you
know it's just not I don't know it's not
there's me but I it's fun it's fun to go
through and
yeah I think if you just read the phrase
as well so if you all free and a go and
get a real sense of where the stories go
no no not for me but death finally how
do people get at you man your website
that sort of stuff
I don't care Tom just cut it off they'll
spam them enough no one [ __ ] cares
make well the links are in description
if everyone you know follow us again
deaf this has been good man thank you
bro
great thank you and thanks for listening
everyone guys love you
[Music]